in on va voir justement si vous êtes
prêt mais on va faire une interview par
amour kamel ouali est ce que par amour
vous seriez prêt à vous déguiser en
elton john à fond ah ouais est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prêt à prendre 17
kg n'ont apporté des nattes
ouais ouais deux petites nattes blondes
savent pas ouais pour une journée ouais
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt à
vous mettre aux drogues dures avec des
n'atteint toujours à quitter la star ac
oui ah ouais ouais j'ai trop de choses
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt à
ce qu'elles commettent quelques
infidélités
ça les énerve déjà quand on aime
quelqu'un on a envie que cette personne
soit heureuse du moins sexuellement avec
moi alors elle n'est pas d'accord il met
un peu alors kamel est ce que par amour
vous seriez prêt à vivre à trois avec
son amant sûr que non sûr que non les
jeunes aillent aussi bien elle et tous
les trois dans un club échangiste non
pour un kiff pourquoi way we ll les
prêteurs gpat en ont l'intention
ou peut être juste voyeur tu me débecte
vous seriez prévenu son esclave sexuelle
par aman avec beaucoup de mal mais
jamais été esclaves sexuels contre lui
quand tu cherchais un mec droit très
belles dents tu là
il est déjà pris